Well, drinking greens first, break a fast.
Well, technically, yes.
So, drinking greens first, if you're doing a true fast,
the answer is yes, you would break a fast.
Technically, if you're doing a true fast,
you could only drink tea and technically not
confidating tea.
It has to be like an urbal flower blend or something.
That's really the only thing you could drink besides water
if you're going to not break a fast.
And even some herbal teas can technically break a fast.
So, you're truly doing just a water fast
that it has to be a water fast.
But it depends on what you're doing the fast for.
If you're just trying to help your body clean out
and you're on a time restricted eating
and you're not eating your meal, tell three o'clock
and your meal, your feeding time is three to six
or three to eight or something like that,
then don't worry about that.
I'm getting the nutrients is important.
So, it really depends on why you're doing a fast.
So, if you're doing a fast for, you know,
where reasons of just helping to heal your body
and I'd say, go ahead and take your supplements,
drink your greens,
don't worry about breaking the fast
or not following the rules of the fast.
If you're doing a fast to really reset your metabolism
and lose weight and do a true water fast,
then you can't drink greens first or protein shakes
or anything like that or you can take your supplements
because you're really truly doing a water fast to lose weight.
Now, there are such things as like a greens first.
There's lots of ways to fast.
So, fast means depriving yourself of something
that's all it means is making a choice to eliminate something.
You could fast television, you could fast, you know,
junk food, you know, that those are all forms of thanks.
But if you're talking about you're doing a fast
to reset your metabolism and lose weight,
then you really want to be at a water fast
for that period of time, not taking anything in.
If you're doing a fast for the purpose
of just trying to get healthy,
then, you know, you should take your supplements too.